The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[FELICE FRANKEL] We're lucky
to have my friend, Brian Hayes,
with us today.
Brian is a writer-- a very
wonderful writer, in fact,
but he also takes
photographs and he
is very good at explaining what
exactly is going on technically
when you make images.
And I thought it
would be interesting
for he and myself to just take a
little more closer look at what
happens.
So I brought Brian
into the studio
to have a conversation
with me and this is what
you'll be listening to now.
[BRIAN HAYES] Hi, Felice.
It's great to be here with you.
[FF] Maybe the place
to start is discussing
pixels and the sensor that's
inside the camera that
records the image.
[BH] We know that the
sensor is an array
of little square
pixels and we know
that the picture that comes out
of the camera in the end when
look at on the
screen or whatever,
that that also is an array
of little square pixels.
And you can't help
yourself just imagining
that there's a simple
one-to-one mapping, that each
of those little
squares in the sensor
corresponds to one of the
squares in the picture.
And it isn't so.
It just isn't so and
it never will be.
There's a computer
graphics person
named Alvy Ray Smith
who wrote the most
petulant academic paper
that I've ever seen.
The title is "A Pixel
is Not a Little Square,
A Pixel is Not a
Little Square, A Pixel
is Not a Little Square."
[FF] I think we understand
what he's trying to say.
Right.
[BH] He's quite firm about this.
And of course, he also has
to admit later on the paper
that a pixel is a little square.
[FF] OK.
[BH] Pixels are what
happened to photography
when it became digitized,
but they're not strictly
an invention.
They existed on film, we
just weren't aware of them
in quite the same way.
And if you translate this
discussion back 50 years,
the question was
then a matter of not
how many pixels do you
want, but how fine grained
do you want your film?
[FF] You bet.
[BH] And the effect
on the finished image
was very similar.
If you chose a film with
large grains of silver,
you got very fast exposures,
tended to get high contrast,
but you also got a lot of
noise and random fluctuations,
especially in dark areas
of the photograph where
it looked mottled.
Now we have a much more
regular geometric structure
with, in spite of what
Alvy Ray Smith says,
little squares, pixels.
And we care about
counting those pixels,
how many millions of
them form an image.
But the question of how much
information is in the image,
how closely can you look
at it before you begin
to see the structure
of the image
rather than the subject
of the image, those issues
have been there from
the very beginning.
[FF] So, for example,
just comparing it
to film, although
most of our students
possibly don't even know
what the word means,
they have seen a
little example of how
we see the difference between
setting the ISO number at 200
as compared to 6,400.
That they will have
seen that there
is a lot of grain and noise,
or appears to be grainy--
that's the word, although
that might not be accurate.
[BH] I don't think that
the difference is worth
bothering with.
[FF] Yeah.
[BH] It is grainy.
It's noisy.
I think that the clearest way
to follow what's happening there
and why that noise
happens and why
ISO matters is to think about
the basic physics of what
you're doing when you
make a photograph.
What you're doing is counting
photons, the quanta of light.
So you expose a piece of film or
the sensor in a digital camera
to the varying
brightness in a scene.
It's focused on the plane of the
film or the plane of the sensor
and what you're doing is in each
small area, the square pixels
on the sensor or the
chemical film grains,
in each small area you're
counting how many photons
strike that spot
within the brief moment
that the shutter is open.
And there's a
statistical issue here.
When a photon hits
the silicon sensor,
it's supposed to
not lose an electron
and it's actually the electrons
that you wind up counting.
When it hits the
film, it's supposed
to catalyze a chemical
reaction that produces
a visible grain of silver.
Both of those things
are somewhat unreliable.
It's-- in part, this goes back
to the deep physics of quantum
mechanics, that some of these
things are probabilistic
and you can't, even if you try,
determine exactly what's going
to happen.
But for a lot of reasons,
when, say, 1,000 photons hit
the film or the sensor, you
may register some other number
other than the exact 1,000.
You might count 900,
you might actually
count more than
there were photons
because some electrons
are just spontaneously--
[FF] Yeah.
[BH] And sometimes the
chemical reaction in the film
happens even without light.
And there is a simple rule
of thumb, a mathematical rule
for explaining why it's so much
better to have a lot of photons
than just a few.
The error that you
get in counting
turns out to be
roughly the square root
of the number of photons.
And so if you have 10,000
photons that you're
trying to count, well,
the square root of 10,000
is 100 and that's
about 1% error.
If you get 9,900 instead
of 10,000 you're 1% off.
And when you translate that
into an amount of light
or the gray level
on an image, 1%
is probably something
you're not even
going to be able to notice.
On the other hand, if
there were only 100 photons
that you were counting, the
square root of 100 is 10
and so you can have an
error of 10% and something--
some pixel might be
10% brighter or darker
than it's supposed to be
and you will notice this.
And in fact, it looks
like snow on the image.
It looks like
random fluctuations
darker and lighter.
And that's true whether you're
looking at a digital image
or a film image.
So you want to capture as
many photons as you can
and that's a complicated
function of how
long the shutter is open, how
wide the aperture of the lens
has been set, and how long
or how sensitive the film is
to light or how
sensitive the sensor is.
And the ISO dial is what
determines that sensitivity.
In the case of film,
there was no dial.
You went to the store
and bought a film
with an ISO rating of
whatever you chose.
With a digital camera you
can adjust it was you wish.
[FF] Almost.
On my camera I cannot get--
I used to use Kodachrome 25.
[BH] I was an Ektar 25.
[FF] You're Ektar.
OK.
And I can't go down
to 25 on my camera.
[BH] That's true.
I would say, however, that
the whole strange historical
accident that we have digital
cameras with a setting that's
labeled ISO is a
little bit deceptive.
Setting something to ISO
26,000 on a digital camera
doesn't match, in any
obvious direct way, what
the setting would be on a film.
And so it's with a
good digital camera,
the noise level that you get
out of it at a low ISO setting
is the equal of anything
that you could have
gotten on your Kodachrome 25.
[FF] So in the
course, we talk about
that because we have
control over everything
we make in this
particular course,
because it's in a
controlled situation,
we are suggesting to set
the ISO at the lowest number
so that we do not pick
up a lot of noise.
[BH] Other things being
equal, that's surely the--
[FF] Let's try to keep
it simple for-- yeah.
[BH] Well, yeah.
[FF] So that's how we're
taking pictures in our course.
[BH] Yes.
If you're taking
pictures of something
that holds still for you--
[FF] Yes.
[BH] --and especially if
you have a tripod so that
the camera also holds still--
[FF] This is the only way we're
taking pictures in this course.
[BH] There would be no reason
not to use the lowest ISO --
[FF] And we can add more
light if we need to.
[BH] Yes.
[FF] So we have control.
[BH] Yeah.
[FF] This is very specific
kind of photography.
[BH] And you have a
luxurious situation.
[FF] Indeed.
[BH] There are occasions
when it's appropriate,
I think, to use a
higher ISO setting.
But what you
described, that kind
of photography, of
course-- why not?
[FF] Why not?
So shall we talk about exactly
what happens to that pixel?
[BH] Sure.
I think the complexity of
it is the kind of complexity
that you don't really need
to understand in detail.
You certainly don't need it in
order to make good pictures.
There have been generations
of brilliant photographers
who knew nothing about
the technology of cameras
and certainly about
the chemistry of film.
However, I think
it's something that
is useful to have in
the back of your head.
And it may change your attitude
toward the images that come out
of the camera and
how you think of them
and what you dare to do to them.
There's a natural
tendency, since we
know that inside
the camera there's
this postage stamp sized slab of
silicon that is the sensor that
receives the light, the
lens focuses an image
onto that sensor.
And we know that's made up of
these little squares called
pixels in a rectangular
array like seats in a theater
or something, you have rows
and columns full of them.
And the picture that
comes out of the camera
is also a rectangular array
of colored squares in rows
and columns, and so it's just
natural to imagine that there
is a simple one-to-one
correspondence
between the pixels on the sensor
and the pixels on the image.
And if only it were that simple.
In fact, if you think
about it a little more,
you realize that it
can't work quite that way
because the square
pixels on the sensor.
I've learned recently
that the professionals who
make these things,
they call them
sensels on the sensor and
pixels in the picture.
But each of the picture
elements on the sensor
has to respond to any light
that it receives of any color.
And in order to take
a color photograph,
you need to have separate
signals for at least
three color channels.
Each sensor element,
then, is actually
made up of four sensor
elements, each of which
has a color filter
pasted on top of it
like the kind of
celluloid filters
that you would use
over a spotlight
or something to
change the lighting,
except of course,
they're very small.
These are arranged
in a pattern so
that each group of
four sensor elements
has two green and a
red and a blue filter.
So right there if you have,
say, 1,000 or a million pixels
in the finished
image-- 1,000 by 1,000,
say-- you actually have
2,000 by 2,000 on the sensor.
There are four million elements
rather than just one million.
So we're already at
that point not having
a one-to-one correspondence
between the sensor
and the picture.
And in fact, it's not
even close to that.
There is no simple ratio.
There are more sensor elements
on the sensor than there
are in the finished picture
and no pixel in the image
actually corresponds to
any one sensor element.
There's an algorithm that
runs on the little computer
inside the camera that looks at
a whole neighborhood of sensor
elements, and by
averaging and filtering
the outputs of a large
number of elements
it assigns a particular color
to each pixel in the finished
image.
[FF] So that each manufacturer
probably has their own formula.
[BH] Very much so.
And they don't tell
us what they are.
[FF] Of course not.
Is it fair to talk about, in
this conversation about pixels,
is this a place
where we could talk
about the difference
between RAW, TIFF and JPEG?
[BH] Sure.
[FF] It would be good to have
an idea about the differences.
[BH] Sure.
So each camera has
a choice of outputs.
Typically, you can get either
RAW or JPEG from most cameras.
And the RAW format is not the
same from company to company,
I guess.
But they're all, apart from
details of file formats
and things like that,
they're all very similar.
It's a collection
of numbers that
represent color values
in a very direct way.
If you looked at the
numbers and assigned colors
to each possible number, and
you took a bunch of crayons
and a big piece of graph
paper with squares on it,
you could actually
reconstruct the whole image
by painting the
appropriate color
in each square based
on just looking
at the numbers in the RAW file.
You wouldn't really
want to do this,
but it's there in principle.
Among the other common
formats, the TIFF
is actually very much the same.
It has the same
information in it,
it's just been rewritten in
a different order, basically.
[FF] Good.
I have conversations with
other photographers who are--
they cannot believe that
I don't take RAW images.
[BH] Well, there's more to that.
If you take a RAW image and
you upload it to a computer
in that form and you use the
appropriate piece of software,
then, to convert
it to a TIFF, you
should have the same set
of numbers in the new file
as you did when it came out
of the camera as a raw file.
On the other hand,
if you take a JPEG
and then convert that
to a TIFF, the numbers
will not match up one for one.
And the reason for that is
that the JPEG format doesn't,
in fact, store this big
array of rows and columns
of color values.
Instead, it takes blocks
of pixels and analyzes
the set of colors found
within each block and then
in order to store the-- well,
not the same information,
but substantially the same
information-- in a smaller
amount of data, it
encodes the information
into a different form.
You might, for example, look
at the whole block of pixels--
I think they're
eight by eight is
the standard way of doing this.
You take those 64 pixels,
an eight by eight square,
and you ask, what's the average
color in that whole block?
And so that's a
first approximation
of how you might
represent the image.
And then you ask, so,
what's the average color
on the right half, and
on the left half, and on the
top half and the bottom half?
And you store that
information also.
And there's a little more to it
than this, but not much more,
actually.
What you wind up with
is a way of representing
the information that is more
compact, but it's not exact.
And when you then reconvert
it to, say, a TIFF file,
you're going to wind
up with something
that's a little bit different.
And certainly, the
purists among us
would argue that
there is damage done
when you go to a compressed
file format like JPEG.
Unquestionably, there
are changes made.
That is, you have altered the
information that is stored.
And the argument is that
these days, with ample disk
space and essentially
the ability
to keep every image you
take in its full form,
why risk losing anything?
That's a good argument, and
I think that, for example,
if you have the ability to keep
both a RAW version and a JPEG
that that's probably
a good idea.
It leaves your options open.
You can always go back
to the original form
and work with it if it turns
out that a particular JPEG isn't
looking the way you want to.
However, I have to
say that this is
based purely on personal
experience and not
scientific investigation.
I've found many cameras
whose JPEG processor
does a better job of
sharpening and color
correcting the image
than I can do myself.
[FF] I'm so happy you
said that because I have,
anecdotally, made comparisons
between my images,
either TIFF or JPEG, enlarged
them like crazy on the screen,
and I don't see the differences.
[BH] Yes.
Yes.
Cameras are very
good, I'm afraid.
[FF] They are, yeah.
And it's a lot of
smart people who've
worked very hard to
make it come out well.
Not to say that you
can never beat them,
but you've got to work
pretty hard to do better.
And it's also worth
keeping in mind,
if only as a way of keeping your
sanity in a world where lots
of people want to
tell you what to do,
it's worth keeping in
mind that a "RAW' file,
in spite of its name, is
not "raw"-- it's "cooked."
The camera has already
done a lot of processing
and it has to.
What would truly be
a "raw" file-- that
is the output of
the sensor directly
without any processing
at all-- it would hardly
look like a photograph.
The dynamic range
would be all wrong,
the colors would be
wildly incorrect.
The camera doesn't see
the way our eye sees
and it needs to be fixed
before we even recognize it
as a photographic image.
This was also true
in the age of film.
If you look at, say,
a color negative,
a piece of color
negative film that's
been processed but not
printed, the entire image
has got a rosy salmon
colored tone to it
that's wildly far from
the correct color.
And that needs to be corrected.
In the old days, this
happened chemically.
It was the film that
you were printing
to from the color negative
was designed explicitly
to correct for that distortion.
And in fact, if
you use that film
to print from a negative that
didn't have the orange cast
to it, you would get something
that was terribly wrong
in the other direction.
It's just never been
the case that there
was a "raw" format
that was truly
some kind of pristine
representation of nature.
It's all "cooked" formats.
And given that, it's sort of
liberating to know that there's
already a whole
lot of processing
going on before the picture
ever comes out of the camera.
And so maybe you shouldn't
be too afraid of turning
a dial or two.
The conception of a
camera as some sort
of objective recording
device that captures reality
without distortion
has never been true.
And even at a very
fundamental level,
when you look at the
physics and technology
of how the machine works.
[FF] OK.
So we talk very
briefly about trying
to get some really wonderful
images for cover submissions,
and we do talk about the
submission should be 300 dots
per inch because that's what the
art directors usually ask for.
And if it's a full bleed
cover, it's 8 and 1/2 by 11,
but sometimes your
images is not that size
so we briefly touch on
putting it into software
and increasing the file size.
There's a lot that goes on
when you click that button,
I'm assuming.
What do you think
about all that?
[BH] Increasing the file
size is really very easy.
As I say, you can
just press a button.
Increasing the resolution
of the image is not so easy.
In some precise sense, you're
not adding any information
to an image when
you simply increase
the resolution in
Photoshop, say, by making it
into a larger file.
If you look at it in the
simplest terms, if you were at,
say 150 dots per inch,
you could take each pixel
and divide it into
four smaller pixels.
Each square becomes
four tinier squares.
Each of those four
squares is identical.
And you then have a file
that's four times as large
in terms of megabytes and
has twice the resolution
and it's now 300 dots per inch.
If you look at the metadata
in Photoshop or something,
that's what it will tell you.
But it has no more information
than the original one.
[FF] OK.
But what we have touched
on with the flatbed scanner
is when we tell the
scanner to scan at,
let's say, 72 DPI and
then we tell it later
to scan at 300 DPI, are we not
capturing more information when
we scan the image?
[BH] Absolutely.
Yes, you are.
You are dealing there
with a physical process
that-- again, if we look at
it in the simplest terms,
and this isn't terribly
realistic-- but
the sensor in the
scanner, when you
scan at reduced resolution,
at, say, 150 dots per inch,
it's going to use two sensor
elements together as if they
were one and simply record
half as much information.
Then when you set the scanner
for 300 dots per inch,
it reads each of those pairs of
sensors as two separate sensors
and records twice
as much information,
or really four times as much
because it's in two dimensions.
The scanner is moving
across the surface,
it's not just one line.
When you do this in
software, however, you
have no way of going back
to the original object
that you were scanning
or photographing
and recording more
information about it.
All you have is what's
in the original file.
Now, this seems very gloomy.
It seems as if you have no
hope of actually increasing
the resolution of an image.
Once you've made it, if you
can't go back to the original
and recreate it from
life, then you'll
never have more dots
per inch than what
you captured to begin with.
It's not quite that bad.
The statement that you can never
put more information into it
than was there to
begin with, it's
true in some mathematical
sense in that
if you have, say, an image
of totally random dots
that are scattered
across the surface
and you try to increase
the resolution in order
to get more dots per inch,
it's not going to work.
All you'll do is make the dots
you have a little bit fuzzier.
But we don't generally
take pictures
of random arrays of dots.
We take pictures of objects
that have macroscopic form, that
have sharp edges,
they have areas
of one color and
another color, they
have smooth gradients of color.
And all of that is structure
at a much higher level
than individual pixels.
And it is possible,
if you're clever
or if your software
is clever, to find
ways to boost the
resolution of an image
that if the image cooperates,
if it's a picture of something
that has reasonable
structure to it, which
could be anything from a
human face, to a plant,
to a technological artifact.
Because reasonably large areas
of color or smooth gradients
or sharp edges and that
these are the things
that you're interested in, it
actually comes out pretty well.
I've done it myself.
[FF] Me, too.
[BH] And in most cases,
the result is successful.
There is a quasi
ethical question
here of do you disclose
to the art director
you're sending this
to that, in fact,
this was a 150 dot per inch
file that you have manipulated--
there's that terrible word-- in
order to boost the resolution?
I'm not an ethicist.
I leave that to other
people to decide.
It's not alteration of
the content, in my view.
It's not like you're air
brushing out something that
wasn't supposed to be there.
But obviously, it
is a deliberate act
to make the picture look better.
I would also say that
another problem here
is that the art director who
insists that the file has
to be 300 DPI is being rather
foolishly rigid about this.
There are images that you can
print on a magazine cover that
are 150 DPI that work out fine.
But changing the world
in that direction
is much harder than
fixing the photograph.
[FF] Especially when the
art director basically
has to first talk to the
editor, who generally knows
nothing about image making.
[BH] As a former editor, I
will let you have your say.
[FF] Thank you.
But no, I would say
for cover submissions
where we're talking
about we're bringing
the notion of aesthetics
and communication,
creating a finer image.
[BH] I entirely agree.
There are various
standards that get applied.
Journalism has one set of rules
that's really quite harsh.
Photojournalists working
for a newspaper or an agency
like Magnum, they
suffer severe penalties
if they're caught making
changes to images.
[FF] Like moving Egyptian tombs.
[BH] Yeah, right.
[FF] Do you remember that?
[BH] I certainly do.
[FF] This was a long time ago.
[BH] In that case, if
I remember correctly,
it wasn't the photographer,
it was the art director
who "improved."
[FF] They moved the pyramids
so that the typeface
could be dropped more properly
as a full cover design.
That was a long time ago.
It's dating us,
Brian, I'm afraid.
But those questions still arise.
[BH] Of course they do, yes.
And it's easier to do
it in the photograph
than it is to move
the pyramid itself.
[FF] As of today, yes, I
would have to say that.
So we are going to be
discussing this in week five,
how far can we go?
[BH] It's a fascinating issue
with a very long history.
[FF] Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
[BH] And it is-- I think it's
something that individuals,
they need to make their
own ethical choices,
but obviously if you're
working in a social setting
where there are other
people making the rules,
you also need to
be aware of that.
[FF] There's a whole
issue as we talk
about the whole notion of
manipulation and how far
can one go.
And certainly in
science imaging,
there are very
serious restrictions,
and there should be.
It isn't all about the
data, but the question
is defining what the data is.
The fact that you're making
an image with a tool,
you're already
changing the data.
We have to remember, and
we'll go back to this later,
but making a picture is
making a representation.
It is not the thing, it
is a re- presentation
and there is some sort of
decision-making involved.
The thing that I'm trying
to emphasize in the course
is that we have to create
a literacy, in a way,
of what makes for
a good picture.
And you and I might disagree
on that, and we have, I think.
And I hope that students
come to their own decisions
about what is better than
that or less than that
and what is good.
But I think we have
to start somewhere,
and the "somewhere" for us
is to create an image that
well communicates what it is
that this device or Petri dish
or thing that we're
photographing-- what picture
can best communicate
the structure?
We're generally
interested in structure.
And if we are talking
about process,
for example, as we do when
we make photo illustrations,
we have examples later
on that the students will
see how I've used bits
and pieces of photographs,
put it all together
for an illustration.
So it's not a documentary image
and there's a place for that
in science.
But in the end, it's about
getting the finest quality
to communicate the science.
That is what we're doing
here in this course.
And by the way, we will
be discussing using
tablets and mobile devices.
Very tangentially, but
there's a place for that.
Absolutely.
When you really, really need to
take a picture quickly and send
it to your colleague to show
them that you have evidence
of what you've produced.
But as far as making the
finest quality image,
we still are going
to-- at this point--
stick to the camera
and the 105 lens.
That's what we're sticking to.
[BH] I wouldn't try
to argue otherwise.
I think the way
people will think
of photography and
of pictures in years
to come may be rather
different from our view.
It's certainly changed within
my lifetime, when photographs
were physical objects
that you put in scrapbooks
or filed away.
We don't think of them
in those terms anymore.
And I think they may
change their nature again
because they are so ubiquitous.
But that doesn't
really have much to do
with the kinds of
photography that
are involved in, say,
scientific documentation
or scientific illustration.
In art photography, you never
know what's going to happen.
And there are lots
of artists, I think,
who are now working with
cell phones and such,
and even with the plastic
lens Lomo cameras and things
that deliberately distort
the view of the world.
So I think there's
lots of latitude
for different
approaches to this.
But for serious documentary
work or for trying
to create the most vivid
image that you possibly can
of something that
holds still for you
while you point the
camera at it, clearly
you're going to use the best
tool that you can come up with.
Even mediocre ones
today, I think,
are considerably better than the
best ones of a few decades ago.
They're probably going
to get better still.